so most people talk about their
headphones I just brought this as a
gentleman so sorry hey GQ my name is
Andrew Rea I make a youtube channel
called binging with babish and these are
my essentials most people come on the
show and they talk about their phones
and their cool Bose headphones in their
life extending face cream me I'm gonna
talk about my meds lactate every should
have lactate I am lactose intolerant
most people are keep some of this around
a surprise you know ice cream cake in
the in the break room boom no problem
pizza you know I got allergies flonase
all day most people don't know this
about me I am deathly allergic to a
mystery thing I went into anaphylactic
shock twice the first time was the day
before my wedding which that didn't work
out
oh man I don't know I was driving
through the countryside to the barn
wedding because it was a barn wedding I
started getting all puffy and I couldn't
breathe and I look in the mirror and I'm
twice my normal size and I'm like oh
Jesus God I have no idea what brought it
on second time I was at a protest I
hadn't eaten or drank anything for six
hours the same deal dual IVs and I go to
the allergist to get checked out get
tested for everything
I'm a little allergic to everything but
I'm not that allergic to anything so
they were like it could have just been a
chemical compound in the air that you
inhaled now I just live in fear all the
time like that could just did it just
walk through the air and kill me
so yeah I carry an epic that with me
these are my antidepressants I take out
of prescence I try to talk very openly
about that because I think mental health
is not discussed openly enough in this
country in the world in general I really
am only doing what I'm doing today and
here and talking to you guys because I
saw help when I needed it
underwear Wow
everybody needs underwear you should you
should have you should have underwear on
right now you don't well I remember the
first time I got like really nice
underwear especially boxer briefs that
really hugged my wish and and it's a it
was it was it was a game-changer like I
can't tell you how nice it is to wear
nice underwear there's way nicer
underwear this this is just what I've
become accustomed to all I can say is if
you've got if you find yourself with 50
hot dollars to drop upgrade your
underwear game cuz it's gonna change
your whole outlook I'm literally it'd be
crazy to come on my essentials and not
talk about some cooking stuff and this
is the thing that I proselytize the most
which is a good chef's knife this is
invaluable this is the most useful tool
that you can get for the kitchen forget
slappy inventions and twisty inventions
that do it all for you and they use
three times and then it breaks just
forget all the gadgets this does the
work of most of the things that you
could buy as seen on TV you know it's a
little beat up is the first chef's knife
I ever got I got it as a gift from my
old bosses done Diana who or still my
dear friends this day and this knife is
still a dear friend of this day it's
still you know I keep it sharp
relatively sharp something us a sheet of
paper do a little test alright so we'll
see if I keep my share of pounds oh yeah
Oh cut that one out this one tool forget
a knife block this one tool is gonna
give you more functionality than most
things in your kitchen and that that's
why I'm a huge advocate for having a
good chef's knife this is an 8-inch list
off classic icon and yeah this will run
you about hundred twenty bucks you want
to step up from there get a shun do not
put it through the dishwasher that will
dull it for sure and it could rust it
which would just be a huge pain they
asked wash it gently wash it immediately
don't let it sit in the sink all time
and he bisharp every once in a while
every year get it professionally
sharpened we've been through so much
together
you can see it's because it's like
battle scarred and it's but it's seen
some stuff it's it's seen some roommates
that have put it through the dishwasher
my friend this is a carving fork but
it's not just any carving fork this is
the carving fork from the movie chef
this was given to me by Jon Favreau in
an episode of my show and I've set a
fish his chef's chef show this is the
actual fork that he used to plate up the
pasta for Scarlett Johansson and then
she just like I the hell out of him he
was kind enough to give this to me and
it's one of my most prized possessions
and most people will ask me when are you
gonna get this bronzed and framed and
know this belongs in my kitchen drawer
and it continues to twirl pasta of this
day watch any episodes that I've done
recently Groff twirl pasta you will see
this fork because this is that's that's
what this was for and you know it's not
gonna break keep keep going I think you
would like knowing that it's still
making pasta
[Music]
timepieces are something that I've
gotten very into as you can see I dress
pretty plainly when I'm on the show it's
a button-up shirt and black apron when
I'm out in the world it's this I always
wear the black Henley my daily wear is
this it's a Rolex two-tone Submariner
gold stainless with a with a blue bezel
and dial I was not expecting to buy this
but I wasn't planning on hitting the New
York Times bestseller list when that
happened I went into a watch shop I told
them I was celebrating they were like
okay we got something in the back they
pulled this out and I was like that's a
little too much for me I put it on my
wrist I was like oh so I got big into
watches about two years ago I guess
there's probably go in chronological
order here this was the first watch that
guy I got it because I felt like I
should get a Rolex things are going well
I should get a Rolex we'll just get the
cheapest one I get my hands on and the
smallest one I get my hands on because I
don't like chunky watches boy did that
change I got it and it just didn't
scratch the itch that I was hoping to
scratch and then a buddy of mine has a
Submariner and I tried it on and it just
changed my whole life
I won this one by accident I discovered
a website called live auctioneers calm
I've never bid on anything in any
auction ever and I just want to see what
it felt like I was like I might as well
be a Rolex and I just put the second bid
down on this I never thought in a
million years that I would win it but
that was it and I want it and I was like
oh I just bought this Rolex
it's from 1981 it's just like the most
80s the most beautiful thing I've ever
seen and I loved it to death and one of
my favorites this is a champagne Daytona
it is quite literally the gaudiest thing
in the world I bought it in like a
backroom watch dealer it was cool I wear
this like empty bomb dad office with
like a bunch of old IMAX wrapped up in
plastic and nobody work in there and I
just needed a corner desk and this guy
pulls an envelope out of his desk with
the watches that I wanted to see it was
the coolest weirdest experience one of
the em arcs of being a watch collector
is getting that watch that's like what
am i doing and that was this watch I was
like oh my god what am I doing with my
life when you put this on your wrist you
feel like Tony Soprano it's like it's
it's next level it's
even though he wears a gold president
don't know where I know what I'm talking
about
this is my workhorse I got this guy to
celebrate finishing my book it's just
you know it's a knock around watch like
you know it's I'm you can see him Dean
I'm trying to be like badass but now I'm
gonna be ginger with it see I can really
toss it around I mostly wear this on the
show because it's not as showy it's not
as like loud
it's a classic watch like it's pretty
much the thing that you picture when you
close your eyes and picture it
Submariner and I love wearing on the
show because it doesn't grab too much
attention it's just great workhorse
watch I can't defend fine timepieces
because I know that like there's no real
reason to spend this much money on
watches but the craftsmanship and the
legend of Rolex its addicting I'm
completely addicted I'll probably only
ever stick to rollies because they
entranced me except is my Cologne
I believe in smelling good I don't think
it costs Lots smell good
you can smell good using a very limited
budget but I wanted to try to get like a
really curated scent so I got this when
I was in Paris I went to the Paris for
the first time last year and I went to
cool parfumerie and I had every
intention of having like one of those
custom cents made but I smelled this and
I was like this is all that is man I
threw it out it's called crazy hours by
Franck Franck Muller of June of it it's
it smells good I like it you would like
it too if you could smell it here sorry
here we have some Kentucky Bourbon 1796
in it it's very good this is sweets and
mellow and complex so it's lovely to sip
on its own but you wouldn't be so shy as
to not make a cocktail from it you could
make a lovely old fashioned with this
and I think that's the sweet spot for
for bourbon obviously I have an
appreciation for really high-end bourbon
but this guy's you know it's 50 bucks in
New York which means that it's probably
35 everywhere else in the world and then
over here I have some lovely songs we
French crystal this was given to me by a
dear friend for my birthday last year
and I love like retro art deco crystal
like this you feel like you're you know
and when you're drinking from something
like this I'm gonna outfit your bar get
some cool really thin we're really
ornate you're gonna feel like a goddamn
king when you drink that's money in the
bank
okay and also you know glassware like
this your kids are gonna inherit this
it's been a long day already basil
Hayden's make mine up basil Aidan's next
up I wear I don't have much of a
prescription that's my dirty little
secret by like 20 40 and this I 20 30 on
this side it's pretty much just like for
watching movies and driving at night but
I feel much more comfortable glasses
especially on camera just makes me feel
like I'm in my little glasses house
these are Oliver Peoples and these are
my bald sunglasses for when I'm not
rocking a hat and then these are my hat
sunglasses these are Tom Ford and these
look better when as you can tell because
they probably look a little weird right
now but these look better what I'm
wearing hat do you agree I'm asking
then tech-easy brush flossers these are
the pinnacle of flossing technology I am
an advocate for daily if not twice daily
flossing I floss at least twice a day
and as such I have never had a cavity I
have never had braces that's not the
reason this is not the reason why that
happened that is pure luck not even
genetics my brother had like headgear
until he was like 17 I've never had a
cavity I use you know not only the
string floss and brush the pics but also
these what I really want to get in
hardcore about it these guys do a job
there is a wire literally a strand of
twisted wire in there with a brush
coming out of it that's what you're
shoving between your teeth this blows
out plaque like a mother that I probably
use these once or twice a week you will
bleed you'll cry you will scream you'll
thank me later
that's my essentials guys thank you so
much for watching thanks for hanging out
I hope that you try some of those things
for yourself and I'll see you next time
on bad wishes 10 non-essentials